Muslim you're Jewish we're dispelling
that myth right off the bat right there
yeah I mean it's a it's a it's a total
farce that I gotta be careful the way I
say this to they're going to try to
ethnically cleanse Gaza yep I mean that
that's and I don't use that term lightly
okay of that now they're just foaming at
the mouth demanding in their words
ethnic cleansing they're talking about
basically removing 2.5 million people
from there okay and honestly they have a
mandate to go seek J and revenge they do
and they would feed me they would insist
that I that I take from them it is just
like the most unbelievable impactful
experiences for me Patrick what did your
pilot guy say I want only Jews in Israel
right okay that that is a form of
ethnically cleansing sorry you know it's
it's emotional for me and just tell him
uh you know how much I support him and
I'm thinking of him and asalam alaikum
greetings of Peace welcome to the deed
show I'm Eddie your host go ahead and
subscribe hit that notification Bell so
you don't miss exciting episodes just
like the next one we have some very very
sad and traumatic and words cannot
express the Heartbreak that is happening
and the world in front of us it's
unfolding so to help shed some light on
what's going on my next guest Dan Cohen
will bring us up to speed shed some
light because there's a lot of
confusion and for the average person who
wants to get to the bottom of things
they're they know that there's much fake
news out there they know what the fake
with the mainstream media is all about
hopefully our next guest God willing Dan
Cohen who is a Jewish journalist and
film maker in his own words I'm a Jewish
guy who had my bar vitma in Jerusalem
and went on Birthright he says he's
lived in Palestine for three years
including seven months get this seven
months he lived in Gaza he's been
looking to debate some of the main heads
who are pushing much of this
atrocity propaganda such as Ben Shapiro
and the like and it's very unfortunate
to see many many people even
good-hearted people who are falling for
it so I challenge you I challenge you to
sit through this
interview if you're sincere truth Seeker
let's bring out my next guest Dan
K love you you're when I was ready to
talk about it I would only talk to I was
explaining how much respect I have for
the Fai of
Islam
the
the hello Dan how are you hey Eddie I'm
great great thanks very much for having
me I appreciate it and an important
moment yes very very it's very heart
heart breaking you know to see all the
latest developments on what's going on
uh just touch upon real quickly when I
when I introduced um this is from a from
a tweet of yours actually that you you
put out that caught my attention and
many's uh can you get into it you
stressed this I'm a Jewish guy who had a
bar mitzvah lived in jeruselam but you
went to the others you lived in Gaza you
know tell us share this experience
uh with with the audience and myself
yeah so um my first stint in journalism
in 2014 in early 2014 I went to
Palestine after you know trying to
figure out what to do with my life and
uh I and I um was there from 2014 to
2017 living uh in Jerusalem in rala um
in
Bethlehem and I ended up getting access
to Gaza I managed to get press
credentials through the Israeli
government and the first time I went to
Gaza was in I want to say July of 2014
at the the last 10 days of the Israeli
offensive on Gaza um in in in the summer
of
2014 and I continued to go back as much
as I could over the next few years while
also covering what's going on in Israeli
Society the West Bank inside you know 48
Palestine um and I made uh throughout
that time that seven months in Gaza you
know filming the destruction the mass
destruction of Gaza itself watching 13
14 story Towers be destroyed by us-made
bunker Buster missiles you know paid for
with our tax dollars um watching entire
neighborhoods be flattened and and
watching peaceful demonstrations on the
border uh or rather along the fence
watching Israeli snipers shoot people
one after the other I turned this into a
documentary um called killing Gaza which
um you know everyone can watch on at
killing gaza. comom it's you can buy it
for five bucks or you it's on YouTube
for free if you don't have if you don't
want to pay five bucks don't worry about
it it's on it's on YouTube so all those
experiences from 2014 to
2017 living in Palestine as a reporter
you know not tied to the mainstream
media um I were just just made
everything totally clear for me I had
the the experience and understanding of
what Zionism is this is not a you know
it's not a not a conflict between two
equal peoples this is the colonization
this is a racist supremacist ideology
that is not real Judaism by any stretch
but weaponizes Juda uses Judaism as a
human shield to advance imperialism and
that's that's what my journalism on
Palestine aims to show and uh and also
on Israeli Society so usually I'll I'll
show some of the U previous interviews
I'd have with um Orthodox rabbis um
Israeli Jewish people to dispel some of
the myths because a lot of times um
they'll say okay this is a Jewish Muslim
thing you know what I mean Muslims hate
Jews but I'm Muslim you're Jewish we're
dis spelling that myth right off the bat
right there yeah I mean it's a it's a
it's a total farce that's actually what
Zionism wants is for us to think this is
some kind of religious conflict because
then it's it's just it's zero sum it's
you know I have my beliefs you have your
beliefs and they're incompatible
incompatible so whoever wins by force
wins but that's not what this is um Juda
Zionism is a pseudo Messianic project
built on the tracks of ancient Jewish
messianism from the times of the temple
and what happened with the destruction
of the Temple is it was a catastrophe
for Jews back then and so the whole Cult
of um of that that Jews did in those
days of animal sacrifice and to worship
um in the temple was ended and rabbis
instead of priests the kohanim which is
my name uh they were no longer in charge
you had rabbis teachers who were in
charge with um preserving Judaism
and so it became a culture of study um
of the Torah of course of scripture but
the whole idea of having a Jewish
kingdom was relegated it was sort of a
genie put back into a bottle um where
because it had caused such catastrophe
and so over the the centuries um this
idea of Jewish messianism would kind of
appear from time to time in uh when
there was social political economic
upheaval but Zionism
thought well we're European nationalists
and and you know there's anti-Semitism
here and so the best way for us to
survive is actually to to join them to
be uh supremacists and say we are a
separate Jewish nation which is a
complete fiction there's all kinds of
different Jewish people from all all
different countries because the religion
spread over the the Millennium so
Zionism took the mythology or the
religion of Judaism whatever you want to
call it and took those symbols as any
European nationalism needed and said we
are going to take the precepts which is
a Jewish Jewish sovereignty Jewish um uh
Army the the return of Jewish people the
so-called return of Jewish people uh
even though you know of course I'm not
indigenous to Palestine and nor is
Benjamin Netanyahu and they created this
mythology they use this mythology to
Nation build the problem is well it's
problematic in itself but it has uh the
logic continues to say well you can't
have a a democratic State this is a
religious State this is a theocracy that
uh the logic of Zionism Zion refers to
Mount Zion where of course alaka is
today and where Jewish tradition teaches
the temples once stood so what happened
over the years is a tiny element of
Zionism that um early on was very uh
small and marginal through
1967 war it was kind of it it got a a
big uh boost and this idea that this was
God's plan coming into fruition this was
a Jewish State a Jewish Kingdom a
Messianic era uh
happening that small tiny movement grew
and grew and grew and they hated the
Peace Accords so the idea of Oslo um of
the um Camp David Accords of the Gaza
withdrawal all of these things
radicalize them because the idea was God
is giving us this land it's expanding
and the state of Israel is Holy it's
God's vessel but if when those Peace
Accords happened they said that was a
crisis for them an ideological
theological crisis and so it became that
we have to actually Force God's hand so
what we need to do is um not just build
settlements but go to the heart of the
entire thing the alaka compound we have
to they so they want to destroy they
want to take sovereignty over the alaka
compound of course one of the most
important um Islamic holy sites in the
world um and of course the most
important in Palestine not only
religiously but culturally and um they
are going and and the idea is we will
take that over destroy it expel any um
uh Islamic presence and build a temple
and return to this big biblical ancient
kind of outdated idea that doesn't they
don't even know what it actually was
because it was an oral tradition passed
on through various
languages um and create that so it's
recreating it's like it's like this very
similar to Isis you know where it was a
bunch of people who don't actually know
the religion who are um who are using it
to advance something completely
different so that's what Zionism is and
that's what we're seeing um even play
out today wow so it would be almost
equivalent to like you have this de you
know Isis we say the insane State what
they're doing exactly and I mean and and
and it's it's funny well funny it's
ironic I guess
because not only are Isis and Zionism
the most kind of extreme and now uh
virulent form of Zionism ideological
twins but they actually collaborate it
was Isis Israel was supporting Isis Isis
in Syria to overthrow the uh Assad
government uh Israel and the United
States directly directly supported Isis
can this can be confirmed people can
look this up absolutely 100% you can
look this up uh the United States was
often called isra uh isis's Air Force in
Syria um the the so-called free Syrian
Army was a CIA project that was
basically just a way to launder weapons
to Isis and so of course we know what
Isis did exterminate minorities in Syria
and it was supported by Israel too
so you know these are these are all like
whether it's you know Nazis in Ukraine
that we've been supporting or Isis and
Syria and Iraq that have devastated
those countries and elsewhere and
Zionism these are all tools of Western
imperialism and so we have to understand
that these are all basically forms of of
the same thing and Zionism has really
nothing to do with uh any sort of you
know decent form of Judaism it is a
perversion uh tell me you've had so many
Aid workers journalists coming out um
speaking about the um war crimes now
that are unfolding the law the
international laws that are being broken
right now and what was what what was
your experience you know you had to have
known much of this in the beginning uh
you probably had this uh this fear to go
over to the to the other side now that
that was um uh being painted is animals
barbarians and what was your experience
like did you have fear your first time
when you went over to Gaza that that you
and and then when you finally went over
what was your experience
like because you were with the IND you
were with the IND indigenous people
there you were living sleeping eating
like is that correct yeah yeah
absolutely yeah no I I all that time I
was um you know staying with with
friends sometimes I was in one of the
hotels for foreigners but the vast
majority of the time I was staying with
friends you know breaking bread with
them sleeping in their in their house
and um I you would think like hold on
you're a Jewish guy they're going to
they're going to chop your head off
what's going on yeah that's what the
propaganda would like you to believe you
know that that exactly that it's this
religious conflict and you know I mean
you'll of course you'll hear uh
Palestinians say you know they they'll
use yahood for you know to talk about
Israelis but that's they're talking
about their occupiers they're they're
not talking about Jews they're talking
about their occupiers of course um my
experience in Gaza was
overwhelmingly positive it's a place
that
holds just you know I hold in my heart
and and it just pains me so much to see
the ethnic cleansing that's happening
right now that that we're watching on
the internet from afar um I mean my my
time there I I was always treated with
Incredible warmth Palestinians I mean
especially if Gaza are really salt of
the earth people um and they have
suffered such so such incredible amounts
uh over the years and years and years
you know they're mostly they're almost
all refugees from what became Israel you
know they're the they're the the grand
the grandchildren they're they're the
sons and daughters and grandchildren of
people who were ethnically cleansed in
1947 1948 the nakba which you know I
don't need to tell your audience um so
my time there I mean if I was ever
scared it was because of Israeli bombing
or when I went to demonstrations uh near
the fence if you come within 300 met of
the fence the completely militarized
wall fence system you will get shot by
an Israeli sniper or by remote
controlled machine gun nests that sit on
top of these concrete walls that're
operated by an all women's unit uh miles
and miles away and they target people by
their gate I've seen them open fire on
people so for me you know there was no
fear of are Palestinians going to do
something to me I mean I'm not openly
advertising that I'm Jewish there um but
I'm I was just a foreigner and there
were other foreigners there were other
journalists that would come and go I'm
an American guy um so I'm an American
journalist and so people appreciated
that I was there particularly after 2000
you know the summer of 2014 when no one
else none of the other journalists were
spending much time there you know they
were going to other places and I decided
no I'm going to continue to spend as
much time to document the what people
are surviving through in the rubble in
the cold winter when babies are freezing
to death or in the hot summer when um
people who had their entire neighborhood
bombed by Israel or living in shipping
containers in the sweltering heat uh
without any sort of Hope but I would go
there and you know i' go to a shiping
container and talk to people and they
would feed me they would insist that I
that I take from them it just like the
most unbelievable impactful experiences
for me so um that's you know those are
the experiences that have given me
Clarity that what I say on Twitter any
I'll debate anybody I don't care who you
are if you want to debate Israel Zionism
there's you don't have a chance um
because you know I know what reality is
and and all of these other these other
frauds you know on on YouTube or
whatever they sit you know they don't
they don't know anything about life they
don't know anything about reality
they're just well-paid
liars they trying to dehumanize the
people this is I want this to stick in
your mind you know some of the most
affluent people you know uh will not
offer you some of their own food they
got all the money but these are people
you're saying in the shipping container
just had their houses blown up and
they're in a shipping container and
they're insisting that you that you eat
from the little that they have I mean
just just think about that um let's get
into a lot of probably my questions um
will be answered through some of these
clips we'll play
um someone who I got to meet uh Patrick
B David he had some guests on just
recently Charlie Kirk I heard you
mention him I don't know him personally
uh but um we've opened up a line of
communication and I hope that he's an
American Christian conservative I'm
hoping that um his heart can soften and
other people's hearts the good Americans
out there I'm an
American uh you're an American also is
correct um so we're Americans who want
good for country good for other people
also and uh it's sad that anytime human
life is precious life these you know
humans are not animals especially babies
uh so I'm going to show you this clip
this from a PB pbd podcast and I'm gonna
I'm gonna hope that uh Patrick sees this
and he invites he keeps it fair and
Balan and he invites Someone Like You on
the program to have a fair and balanced
discussion on the topic so let's go
ahead
and take it to Charlie Kirk he what what
he has to say we'll show a few of these
clips and get your your uh response to
that when I took a helicopter ride from
Jerusalem to the Gaza border it's 45
minutes wow 6 hours they're live
streaming the killing of Jews was did
somebody in the government say stand
down that is a legitimate nonc
conspiracy question the whole country is
the IDF the whole country is yeah and
you're trying to tell me that they're
going to concerts and kutzas and schools
and by reports 6 hours let's say it's 3
hours that's
suspect go ahead Rob it's also not like
a right-wing uh reporting this is from
The New York Times the long wait for
help as mass unfolds in Israel I can't
think of a more liberal news Outlet than
the new yorktimes and and but by the way
I I'm actually very pro-israel so let me
be very I mean so I'm not exactly I
think we all are no no I just want to
make sure my position is clear here so
they start off here with this there's
some thing about suspect like is it
possible that this thing is set up
because who benefits from all this the
Palestinian people at the end now 50%
who are children are being just
annihilated what do you think from the
conversation that's starting off there
they start off with u this is
suspect well I mean you know I think the
what actually happened here what led to
this operation from from Gaza um is just
the simple people are looking for
something
conspiratorial I don't see that what I
see I mean I guess it's possible but
what I see is that um the Israeli
government led by the the by by Benjamin
Netanyahu basically ignored warnings
they you C it's I mean the simple fact
is you cannot keep a population Under
Siege indefinitely um especially one
that has weapons and expect that they're
not going to try to take their freedom
to fight back um you can you know
question what happened in those
settlements and you know if there were
civilians killed then you know that's
certainly awful and you know that that's
all up for debate but what's not up to
for debate is Palestinians right to
resist um so if you you know when you
keep people in a cage in a ghetto you
bomb them you starve them you keep them
under siege and then you take some kind
of you put the softest targets these
settlements right on the other side of
this hyperm militarized fence and wall
system and you know that people can get
out that that militants can get out you
put these soft targets these kutes these
Israeli settlements and you have some
kind of concert filled with young people
who are all of military age many of them
are soldiers in fact there were military
vehicles there uh that's that you can
see in accounts from from uh Israelis
who survived and escaped that you are
basically asking for some kind of attack
for some kind of operation and so you
know to Fain outrage well the outrage
should be directed at Israel at the
Israeli government for keeping these
people in a cage treating them like
animals because what
happens with anyone when you treat them
like an animal eventually they're going
to act out in some way that you don't
like and so that's you know that's
happened again and again and again and
this is just maybe the most you know
this is the most severe example of it in
years and years so you know Charlie Kirk
and these guys they're simply unable to
understand that they're looking for some
for some conspiratorial angle um because
they can't understand why why that would
happen and why you know Netanyahu
they're drunk on power I mean they're
all about expanding settlements in the
West Bank they thought Gaza is a done
deal um and Hamas played its hand very
strategically it ignored um you know
stepping into to confrontations before
in order to sort of play koi um and and
Israel also Al we know that it warned it
ignored warnings directly from the
Egyptian government that something was
imminent from Gaza so I mean there's the
actual intelligence that the Netanyahu
government ignored and there's just the
overwhelming overwhelmingly obvious
logic that you keep people in a cage
they're going to try to get out and it
it's going to be ugly so um you know
these guys are just too um they're
incapable or they're or they're dis
honest and they won't they won't
entertain that the elephant in the room
let's go to the next clip here the
Israeli hard right government has a
mandate I gotta be careful the way I say
this to they're going to try to
ethnically cleanse Gaza yep I mean that
that's and I don't use that term lightly
okay they're talking about basically
removing 2.5 million people from there
okay and honestly they have a mandate to
go seek Justice and revenge they do
there is they this idea that they need
to have a TR truce or a peace treaty
that's morally crap after you see women
and children be burned alive and dragged
to the streets but they have a right to
seek Justice
Revenge at what cost even if you go with
an eye for an ie uh is that mean a eye
for two million innocent people what
what do you what do you say to um to
this um response or statements by char
well it's even worse Charlie Kirk didn't
say they have a right he said they have
a mandate that they have to mandate and
so what he you know if Charlie Kirk were
were uh a pundit in during during World
War II during the Warsaw Ghetto Uprising
he would be cheering on the Nazis to go
in and exterminate every single
inhabitant of of the ghetto that's what
he sounds like this is not about
protecting Israel or Israeli uh you know
civilian I or anything like that he's
talking about ethnically cleansing in
his
words a
ghettoised de demonized people most of
whom you know much of the population
more than half well more than half of
the population of Gaza are children I
mean you go anywhere in Gaza there are
children everywhere that's what he wants
to do I mean this is just genocidal
rhetoric and and it's open he doesn't
even try to hide it between discourse
about security and protecting and any of
that now it's just out in the open these
guys are are just straight up fascists
it's it's just wild to see and
especially I don't know about Charlie
Kirk but a lot of these kind of populist
right-wing guys were against the Ukraine
war you know they had this kind of phony
anti-war um rhetoric and they've just
dispelled with all of that now they're
just foaming at the mouth demanding in
their words ethnic cleansing it's just
the most
depraved display uh I've I've really
ever seen on on on television these
kinds of things I mean you know as um I
mean we as Muslims we love Jesus you
know and then you often hear um
Christians who I feel sad have jumped
into this whole Zionist thing now other
Christians who are in Palestine who are
also being oppressed um correct me if
I'm ever wrong here and and now you
you're going away from what Jesus or the
prophets of God or any god- conscious
person is about
spreading peace Justice Prince of Peace
you know which we believe he is but what
where at what C now it's like all that's
out the window what where's your moral
compass your moral code it's like now
you know these are children we're
talking about am I correct 50% of Gaza
is children more more than 50% more than
50% exactly these are not little animals
I mean these are CH and even even now if
you were if you were talking about there
probably more people ironically who
would be stand these were dogs out there
and they had two million dogs you'd
probably have more people you know who
would be coming out to save the dogs
yeah exactly exactly I mean it's it's
it's just I don't even have words for
how horrible that is you know one here's
another thing about Charlie Kirk he's
not only a he's not only advocating
openly ethnic cleansing he's also an I
mean he's saying you know getting all
the expelling all those people he's also
liar he tweeted I'm going to read you
exactly his tweet this is about the 40
beheaded babies deception that went
around he said they found the bodies of
40 Jewish babies some with their heads
cut off pray for Israel in the next
tweet shortly after he says oh this
might be
misinformation so we have to be careful
it was soon debunked the whole thing
about 40 ham debunked de is like okay
totally fake there's no evidence of it
the Israeli prime minister's office 2
days after the the incident tweeted out
a photo that apparently was made with uh
artificial intelligence an AI photo
there is not a single parent who or
family member who has come forward to
say one of my you know I'm the parent of
one of these supposedly beheaded babies
there's not one um name released there's
not a photo there's we don't you know
from before they were supposedly killed
anything like that oh yeah not only that
we have yeah the source is a is a
fanatical Israeli settler who who wants
to commit genocide um openly this is
this is the actual Source yes this is
the source who went to the Israeli News
Outlet I24 and uh which is controlled by
Benjamin Netanyahu and um and said I I
want to do that so this has been I mean
this is what this is is an intentional
deception and Charlie Kirk actually
admitted it this might be
misinformation and then it was debunked
and then he goes on and still promotes
it the next day he's still promoting I
mean where's the Integrity the honesty
truthful all this is out the window now
you hear this also constantly being
repeated by um Ben Shapiro and the
like and he's he's he's looking to draw
the emotion the reaction from the
American public uh saying would you do
this going into civilian Villages he's
quoted and kill babies uh burning
families raping women Gra women would
you kill a baby this is Ben Shapiro
asking these qu questions but then now
people like you and others are
uncovering that this is all there's a
there's also another American here his
name is Jackson hle yeah yeah Jackson
Hinkle and others are coming out these
are Americans and others who are who are
to these claims now this atrocity
propaganda that's being pushed they're
coming out they graped women this is
unsubstantiated claim that the LA Times
actually
retracted uh this girl she's still alive
in Germany she can come out if she was
raped she can testify right well she's
in she's in Gaza she's held captive in
Gaza I mean she was uh the last report I
had basically they said that they killed
her and they raped her which was um not
true her mother came out and said that
she's actually um on in on critical
support in the hospital in Gaza and is
being treated so I mean all of those
what you just showed that list that
Jackson Hinkle came up with are just one
lie after the other after the other and
the biggest one is the 40 beheaded
babies now I mean I look at what
happened in those settlements in those
kutes and all of that stuff and I think
well that's horrible that is awful what
actually happened there's no doubt about
it why does the Israeli government feel
the need to lie about it why does
Charlie Kirk why do all these
propagandists feel the need to lie to
exact exaggerate well it's because they
want to generate blood lust in their
foreign audience to justify the ethnic
cleansing that he's calling for that
he's demanding and that the Israeli
government is actually carrying out at
this very moment as we speak now a
normal person I would think would find
out oh 40 head 40 babies weren't
beheaded oh that's I'm relieved I'm glad
but instead no he wants they want 40
Israeli babies to have been beheaded
because then it would justifi they want
to sacrifice these babies so it can
justify the murder the mass murder and
ethnic cleansing of of Palestine that's
how demented these people are this is I
just I don't for educational purposes I
want to show you something I I don't
know if you're aware of this but just so
you can see you know this is the The
Stance of of Muslims here following the
instructions of prophet Muhammad peace
and bless upon we have no anyone who
goes against this I mean this is what we
condemn uh can you see this that's up on
the uh on the on the screen uh the
killing of innocent uh children uh women
you know mutilating bodies cutting down
of um trees you know attacking churches
monasteries uh synagogues whatever the
case religious sites uh destroying you
know uh the villages Town this is
something that is clear so I just want
to make this clear this position that
you know and anybody who does something
outside of that they're going outside of
um what is um um sanctioned so let's get
into the next clip here and get your
reaction to thisly on that because th
that is a very slippery slope and if you
actually want to talk about what
Jews and even Christians uh should be
most fearful of Muslims as well is the
concept of ethnic okay cleans I just
want to be very Sor sorry to interrupt
I'm saying that's what they're going to
be accused of correct but if there are
some people in public life in Israel
that Patrick what did your pilot guy say
I want only Jews in Israel right okay
that that is a form of ethnically
cleansing because 20% of Israel is Arab
mus correct 20% and people don't don't
know that and I've been to Israel
several times I was there a few months
ago and I saw the protests yes you know
if you don't have to be uh uh uh seems
like they realized the Adam there who's
one of the co-host it seemed like he
realized the severity was you know what
they're what they're dealing with here
um what are your thoughts I mean you
know they said it and then it was like
wait a minute because you know uh
Charlie Kirk said I have to be really
careful how I say this ethnic cleansing
yeah I'm going to say it he thought
about it that wasn't an accident I slip
he said it explicitly because that's
what he wants and then he thought oh
wait maybe you know my producers in my
ear telling me maybe I shouldn't say
that so I mean that's just he now not
only is he is he does he want to see
ethnic cleansing and is he does he want
to see 40 beheaded Israeli babies and
millions of kill Palestinians killed he
uh uh he's a liar he can't then he can't
even be honest about it I mean it's just
the most it's if if any of these people
got challenged you know if I mean can
you imagine if I was able to go
head-to-head with them if I was able to
to debate them like we're talking right
now live unscripted I mean they'd just
be humiliated they would destroyed and
discredited but they're all fraud so
they won't talk to me they're all I mean
how do these people sleep at night I
don't I don't get it Eddie it's just
like ju they're just they're you know I
guess on a big pile of money that's all
I can all I can say my my my Dan my
intention is to you know because we're
we're all human beings and my sincere
intention is to try to with these
program to try to awaken any Humanity
that someone has in their hearts even be
Charlie whoever the case you know to
bring out the the good you know I mean
to work towards a peace and
understanding and obviously you can't
have uh peace without justice so when
you when you bring to light you know we
can understand you know if we get if
we're in a traffic jam if somebody gives
us a ticket unjustly or somebody you
know imagine someone coming into your
house you know talk about that for a
moment before we go to the next clip you
know imagine someone from New York comes
to your house we get people get in an
uproar you know you have incidences like
um a cop May oppresses someone the whole
town goes you know berserk and whatnot
and then imagine like you're somebody
someone comes in your house has been
your house for Generation to come and
now they come in and they have all the
soldiers to back them up and they're
forcing you out and you know children
dying this is something that's not
happening on a regular basis you know uh
and and and no media coverage on this
this is not talked about and then the
people when they're challenged I don't
know if you saw that I don't know if you
posted that the person that when when
the person the per the Zionist is
challenged on some of these things it's
like no one really challenges it asks
them to condemn but then when there
there was a clip of Sky News when the
person was I don't know if you saw that
one the former
something and what about those
Palestinians in hospital who uh are on
life support and babies and incubators
whose life support and incubator will
have to be turn off because the Israelis
have cut the power to
Gaza are you seriously keep on asking me
about Palestinian
civilians what's what's wrong with you
have you not seen what happened we're
fighting Nazis talk to us for a moment
about paint that picture so people can
really understand on one side is it true
I spoke to uh many people were also
there I don't know if you heard of Miko
pet have you ever met him I know Miko
yes yes uh he's also an Israeli Jew his
his father was one of the original or
his grandfather sign signers of the
Declaration Independence I really
recommend people to look into his work
and and many people talk about it you
can you can talk about because you
firsthand live there on one side of the
fence you have clean running water the
other SES if you have dirty water
electricity B let's talk about that you
know and then also the the settlers you
know the legal un has constituted this
this is breaking of international law uh
help people understand this so this can
this can um really hit home and people
can put themselves in that situation put
yourselves
in this in this picture that you're
about to um the reality of this
paint well I mean the Gaza Strip is one
of the most densely populated places in
the world it's about 2.5 million people
now I mean when I was there I think it
was it had just hit 2 million people so
the population continues to grow
massively um and so again it's mostly
children it's less it's smaller than the
size of Manhattan for example there is
essentially no open space so it's all
buildings it's all built up um and about
I think 20% of that land even is uh noo
zone so if you get within you know
hundreds of meters of the Israeli uh
controlled fence they'll shoot you a
sniper will shoot you as I explained or
remote control uh uh um machine gun will
shoot you you have constant drones
humming above your head which kind of
sounds like a a symphony of lawnmowers
just constantly reminding you that at
any point someone sitting in a military
base 50 miles away looking at you from
above can with the flip of a switch turn
your life off kill you or your family or
anyone else um so the the stress the
dehumanization I mean it is a
concentration camp there's no other way
to describe it um the Israeli military
actually calculated the amount of
calories that each gazin is allowed to
consume in a day and so the idea is to
keep this could verify are you serious
they calculated the the amount of
calories that what yes 100% that's
absolutely true it's widely reported um
um yes they they they calculated that so
in order to keep people malnourished but
not quite kill them the whole idea is to
keep the place on life support because
it has served as a warehouse for
Palestinians in order to have this
Jewish demographic majority that is
artificially engineered in Israel so you
know people uh so like American Jews and
zionists can go and enjoy their lunch in
Tel Aviv or go to Jerusalem or wherever
and not see very many Palestinians you
have to keep them in a cage and so
that's what that's what Gaza really is
and it's only now that they've shaken
their cage every time they shake their
cage then the Israelis come in and you
know try to pound them into submission
but um like any Patriot anyone who
values freedom and liberty knows that
will never happen people would rather
die fighting for their freedom than than
to live on their on their knees and so
you know that says nothing of course on
the on for for the children who never
make any decision to resist or not um
there's a few hours of electricity per
day uh Israel has repeatedly bombed the
um Power Plant the sewage facilities so
sewage flows openly into the street and
into the into the ocean uh sorry into
the Mediterranean Sea so even if you
want to go into the sea and go for a
swim the only way gsin have to relax and
um and to maybe disconnect a little bit
uh you're there's a good chance you'll
be swimming in fresh sewage um you have
uh water there is uh no clean water um
from the tap and the shower or the sink
so you get uh sea water um so you know
every time you take a shower you have
that that salt you have that salt on you
the only way you get clean water uh for
drinking is through deliv delivery um
which is a very profitable Enterprise
for Israeli businesses that's been
that's another key part of it is the the
complete destruction of um the
Palestinian economy to create a a
dependence economy for Israel to exploit
so um in every way it is a concentration
camp um I would say a vastly more
technologically sophisticated
concentration camp than we've ever seen
and what I mean by a concentration camp
is it concentrates the population um so
the Nazi concentration camps were not
the only ones in history there have been
uh that that has been used in in various
contexts in Vietnam the United States
used concentration camps for example um
but Israeli concentration camps that's
what the Gaza Strip is and so um now
because of this Hamas operation to
attack those settlements and to take
Israeli hostages in in order to use them
to negotiate for their prisoners which
is the idea of taking
hostages uh the Israelis have decided
now it's time to turn the uh
concentration camp into a extermination
camp we're going to exterminate we're
going to ethnically cleanse it and
exterminate anyone who stays in here and
probably people who are on the well
they've actually they gave the orders
for the northern roughly third of Gaza
for all of the residents to move South
which is a physical impossible task
you're talking about more than 1 million
people going through a tiny area um it's
it's completely impossible and now
they're going to start bombing is what
they said we we're giving you several
hours and we're going to start massively
bombing that area and then as people are
moving south as they heated those orders
they started bombing them so it's
psychological warfare um to just they
want to kill as many civilians as
possible and at the same time you're
seeing um figures like Simka Rothman the
uh member of of Israel's Israel's
parliament saying uh our goal is for a
Jewish child to be able to walk through
Gaza
unharmed so that's the same thing
Charlie Kirk is calling for an ethnic
cleansing they want to remove every
single last Palestinian from the Gaza
Strip just as they attempted to do in
1947 1948 and achieved largely um and
they've tried to do throughout the rest
of the land so they want to they want to
send them into the Egyptian
Sinai um and have them permanently live
in tent camps as the um Israeli Member
of Parliament betel smotrich said and so
you know I mean whether you want to call
that genocide I don't know I'm not a
legal expert but it's certainly these
Israeli officials have expressed intent
to genocide and without a doubt have
committed crimes against humanity and
that's what we're witnessing right now
that's what the Gaza Strip has become in
the last four days is that why it's
really important for them people like
Ben Shapiro and the like to push out
much of this fake news these hoaxes that
are out there for instance when he was
asked he was pushed to produce evidence
he put out he put out a tweet that had a
burned what seemed to be a burned baby
and then he got tagged what is it
Community noted that it was an AI image
yeah it's even it's even worse than that
that image came out from the Israeli
Prime Minister's office the official um
the official Twitter account of Benjamin
Netanyahu they they put out three images
saying that this is proof of 40 beheaded
Israeli babies and and burned beheaded
and burned Israeli babies now one of
those images this is the same one that
Ben Shapiro promoted as proof of this um
I mean on its face that's not proof okay
one of the images for example there's
there's there's no you can't tell that
anything has been beheaded I mean and
it's it's so it's so so Grim to be
discussing these details that that's
what they force us to do to talk about
this um but you know without even
without going into the whole uh me
debunking the whole thing one of these
images yes is apparently AI generated so
the so I mean it's just unbelievably
cynical it's beyond anything I could
ever comprehend that they're using a
fake image apparently I mean I can't say
this is 100% but they are at least using
Imes that don't prove what they're
saying and um and possibly are created
one of them created with artificial
intelligence to justify the ethnic
cleansing of Palestine that's that's
what's happening this has happened in
the past for people who remember the
incubator babies with Iraq so people can
get home these things happen this is
this is part of getting
dehumanizing the the other side that you
want to exterminate and because the
American public uh and people around the
world they're not going to support you
hopefully they if their hearts are open
if they have any Humanity in them
they're not going to want to send their
money what is it like three over three
billion dollars uh to that's sent yearly
annually so this is it's very important
that people understand this uh to get
the people support they have to program
them and they have to make people look
like animals so they push what you
brought up earlier this whole 40 babies
and all of this uh fake news uh because
nobody wants to see babies killed but
it's ironic now on the other side now
you're seeing it in front of you
happening that you're seeing uh you have
a friend of yours actually I was going
to find the clip but you have a friend
of yours who's in Gaza and he was taking
on Instagram people can go we'll try to
get this this uh up that people can see
and in real time he's showing uh if you
can help me with with the the name
what's his name m AA yes yes yes that's
that's the one and he's actually in real
time he's showing you're seeing actually
baby Parts you're seeing like you saw
those you obviously saw what he's uh
posting on his uh on his Instagram it's
very sad it's it's just uh out of this
world I cannot believe in real time this
is unfolding motaz is a uh portrait
photographer that's what he's he's one
of the sweetest most childlike people
I've ever known in my life um that's
what he wants to do is be a portrait
photographer and because of the
circumstances that he that he was born
into because of Zionism he's forced to
be a war correspondent or a war
instagrammer documenting the ethnic
cleansing going on around him of his
people and yesterday uh and he's been
braving the bombardment going outside
and going to the the scenes of fresh air
strikes and watching the most horrible
things that we could imagine that you
know God forbid anyone else has to ever
see in their life and yesterday he went
to his uh an an a home that had been um
struck in his neighborhood his home
neighborhood and it turned out to be his
family his father's side of the family
15 at least 15 people who were killed
and so and he documented it and um I
mean it's just beyond you know anything
I can imagine when we you know Israel is
lying about 40 Israel and Ben Shapiro
and Charlie Kirk all these guys all the
mainstream media are lying about 40
beheaded Israeli babies meanwhile
they're bombing people to where they're
just it's just body parts you look at
the body bags in my you know I have it
on my Twitter I showed his mot's videos
that are on his Instagram it's body bags
listed with parts of this person and
parts of that person and there's a
question mark which which body part is
who who who's this body part belong to
and so you know that stuff will never be
talked about in mainstream media um or
or by any of these these professional
Liars calling for ethnic cleansing so I
mean it's just you know it's it's just
beyond words Beyond
Comprehension um what is what is
happening and I very much fear for M's
life um you know I'm constantly checking
his Instagram and WhatsApp to see if
he's logged in and I this is it here
right this is him right here it's him
yep you can follow him on Instagram
mzore
AA um you have to follow him in order to
uh to to be able to see him Instagram
restricted his feed to people only who
follow him so they're censoring him too
soft censoring but I mean you know at
any moment he could just be killed and
uh I I've been texting him just messages
of support and I called him yesterday
afternoon here in in Washington DC where
I am was probably 11 o'clock midnight in
Gaza and he answered I mean he's just
such a kind soul and he's he's
completely
exhausted emotionally and physically and
in every way and he answered and we
talked for a few minutes and I just
tried to cheer him up and tell him how
important what he's doing is and and
um sorry you know it's it's emotional
for me and just tell him uh you know how
much I support him and I'm thinking of
him and and like we even managed to
share a laugh so I mean it's just
uh just beyond comprehens it's just
crimes against humanity that's that's
all I can say I you know some somebody
has to intervene to stop this you know
we we hear about the us we hear about
responsibility to protect that was the
justification for bombing Libya for for
so for you know we we we're protecting
people in Syria and Ukraine all these
places meanwhile we are underwriting the
ethnic cleansing of Palestine at this
very moment and uh you know the state
department even circulated memos among
its staff today this was reported by The
Huffington Post saying make sure you
don't do don't do anything like calling
for a ceasefire or deescalation or
negotiations those words are all banned
in the state department
so I
mean they're banned in the state dep
what can Americans do now what can
Americans you know people who are
watching this you know people like
uh uh out there who are actually um you
know people like Jackson hickley I don't
know who this person is but I'm just
seeing that he's a to some of the things
that are going on and yourself and
others uh what can what can people do
who they don't um they don't approve of
this it's the first time you know
they've been they've been watching the
mainstream media now they got outside
their box they're watching some
Independent News they're getting a whole
different picture because I don't think
anybody can really you know look into
this you've had some of the um some of
the social the the celebrities like the
Justin beavers LeBron James right
probably giv a script by their managers
pushing stuff out have you seen some of
these right but I don't think if they if
they did what you did if they did what
some of these others did and they really
took a how can how can a person took a
deeper dive I guess that's my question
to to kind of get beyond the the
mainstream headline approach because
they know most people don't go deeper
they just read the headlines so that's
why they put all this fake news out
there and then that's what's stuck in
the head job is done finished but but
people who are watching us now and I and
I I really um I call upon you know
someone um like Patrick B David who has
a big following he's talking about this
invite Dan on invite people who will
give you the other side and let people
judge from there let let's be fair let's
have the debate let's go ahead and talk
about it you know from both sides um so
what what advice would you have for your
average person average American uh
person who just has very little uh
knowledge on this how can they get more
informed yeah I mean first thing I would
say is stop watching televis Vision
because it's all the same exact
messaging it's all controlled um it's
all deceptions and it's very hard to
know what's true and what's not if
you're not well-versed and you're not
you know following it in a in to the
level of kind of granular detail um I
mean if you want to get a sense of what
Gaza is really like you can watch my
documentary that I made what's that
called what's that called again it's
called killing Gaza okay people can
watch that killing go.com I mean if you
you know like I said it's five $5 to buy
it on there or $3 to rent it that will
help me with my work um which is sorely
needed or um you can watch it for free
you can go to YouTube If you don't have
you know five bucks to spare right now
no problem go watch it on YouTube for
free um or on Vimeo it's also on Vimeo
for free we made it free a couple years
ago I made that with Max Blumenthal the
the journalist um and um so you know
that'll give you a sense of what Gaza is
like I also did a film from mint press
news on Gaza that Motas AA filmed it's
called Gaza fights back um you can find
that on on it's on my Twitter it's also
uh on mint press news's YouTube channel
if you look up mint press news Gaza
fights back you can see it there um you
know if anyone can't find it just tweet
at me I'll I'll I'll send it out um I'll
retweet it even I put it up yesterday um
you know but you can watch go on social
media go on Twitter follow what Motas is
doing look at what people who are
actually showing you what's going on is
doing not people on television who are
explaining their analysis or their
opinion or you know I mean not that it's
bad to I mean I'm obviously giving you
my opinion on my analysis but I you know
I'm someone who's actually been there um
not on the corporate media they're all
they're all well-paid liars that's their
job and that that job has now turned
into what Charlie Kirk is doing inciting
ethnic cleansing and lying about
beheaded babies and and this kind of
thing so um you know that's it's it's
it's not a very complex issue it's you
know what what American Patriots who
believe in in freedom and liberty like I
said someone was en encroaching on your
land well I mean a lot of people you
know believe in the second second
amendment and that's what many people in
Gaza feel too that they support the
resistance um because they have no other
choice it's a battle forther it's it's
either it's live you know on their knees
or or uh or die you know it's basically
the choices they're given now it's kind
of like um What analogy can you give uh
or have you given like if somebody comes
into your house and now is um trying to
force you out forcing you out at
gunpoint um killing your family
members uh and even before that you go
deeper you you know these are people who
actually live together in peace and
Harmony Jews Christians and Muslims
before this whole Zionist movement came
in so now uh now you want to put them on
even playing field now now you end up
someone goes and and and and fights back
against the the person who's in the
house attacking attacking the the family
and now they're C now the victim is
being made uh in this equal playing
Ground as the aggressor as the
criminal that that's that's not uh
that's how they're trying to make it
seem
like uh but it's it's clear as day if
you look into this uh people when you
just a couple more questions when you
when you look at um this term apar tide
people like Nelson Mandela have called
it this Jimmy Carter the US president
and human rights is isn't it true that
human rights organizations also Israeli
human rights organizations has also
called this an apartheid state can you
can can you talk about this for for a
moment yeah I mean the apartheid label
is not even controversial at this point
um it's long been an apartheid state
just two two legal systems even within
so-called Democratic Israel it's an
apartheid state you have U many
discriminatory laws that are
specifically against Arab citizens
Palestinian citizens of Israel let alone
the various kind of
um levels of citizenship or
noncitizenship or residency
for Palestinians in Jerusalem and the
West Bank and Gaza I mean it is by
definition an apar regime that's just a
it's almost like a bland statement now
um but as you mentioned the Israeli NGO
bet selm uh has long called it an
apartheid state so um I mean it what
what South African apartheid was pales
in comparison to what the Israeli
project is the Zionist project which you
know the the South Africans were not
using F-16 to bomb entire neighborhoods
to wipe out entire neighborhoods they
weren't you know firing artillery
blindly into densely populated
neighborhoods of children into Shanty
towns that's what Gaza that's what Gaza
is where you know now they want to
ethnically cleanse an entire third of it
and bomb the people as they're fleeing I
mean this is a this is another level
this is what Charlie Kirk demanded
ethnic cleansing uh so and that's what
Palestinians have suffered for years and
years and years since their grandfathers
or the youngest ones even their
great-grandparents you know and there
are very few survivors left of the nakba
the catastrophe of 1947 1948 that just
you know on the ruins of Palestine where
the state of Israel was
established um those you know that's
that's what has gone on every day so
today is another nakba and that's that's
what's happening so I you know I'm
just praying hoping that um some force
will intervene to stop Israel whether
through diplomatic or military means
they have to be
stopped God bless you thank you very
much uh where can people go ahead and if
they want to follow you and connect with
you look more into your documentary
where can they go um you can um my my uh
work is all on on my Twitter at danen
3000 you can follow me there you can
message me
um you can you can reach out to me I'm
very always happy to hear from from
people who are interested in my work um
the documentary killing Gaza excuse me
is at killing gaza. comom um the then um
I'm actually have another documentary
project that is extremely urgent I'm
trying to finish in the next as soon as
possible uh regarding um the situation
in Palestine specifically about alaa the
alaa compound and so if any it's you
know if anyone wants to defend alaxa
which is very much under threat at this
moment because of course this is not
going to stay in the Gaza Strip these uh
you know hardcore these these fanatical
Zionist forces would love nothing more
than to destroy aloa um and they see it
as a big yellow button to press to
launch the the kind of war that they
actually want um then you know please
consider uh on on my on my tweet my
first tweet my PIN tweet I have a link
to go buy me a coffee I also have
patreon I also have substack you can
donate um anywhere there to to support
my project that I'm this documentary
that is essential that I'm trying to get
out and I'll be able to announce more
about it and release a trailer very soon
I just can't do it quite yet um so thank
you so much for for having me and I
appreciate you know your your platform
and your integrity and uh thank you
thank you free Palestine Thank you very
much may um God bless you and we call
upon the piers Morgans and Patrick B
Davis and others you're ready for debate
you're ready for discussion on the on
the issue if they invite you're ready to
go let's get this uh send this out tweet
this out pass this video on to to them
and their channels and uh let's demand
that what the viewers want to see so
they can make an informed a properly
informed uh decision you're down for
that huh 100% anytime um you know I
don't even I don't need to be
disrespectful or call anybody names I'll
just calmly debunk um you know the the
the the claims and the lies and and you
know we'll talk about what's true and
what's real and how we're actually going
to protect human life not only
Palestinians but Israelis too let's all
all human life yes exactly thank you
very much God bless
you brothers and sisters this is your
brother Hass CH and I'm so excited so
grateful to Allah subhana to be standing
right here at the dean center that is
being established in Tampa by brother
Eddie from the dean show we are so
excited that he's chosen Tampa to be
this Hub and Center for dawa not just
locally alhamdulillah where we can host
seminars programs daa activities there's
enough space for a school gymnasium uh
Mah and a studio that can inshah reach
people globally to share the beauty of
Islam we're so excited to have this
established here locally in Tampa and I
want to encourage you all do what you
can to help complete this project and
make it a reality and I invite you all
to join me supporting the center may
Allah make it a for all of us to share
the beauty of the dean with all
[Music]
Humanity I cannot leave without giving
you a gift if you're not yet Muslim and
you tuning in to see what these Muslims
are talking about and you like a free
copy of the Quran go ahead and visit the
Deens show.com we'll take care of the
postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions about Islam call us at 1
662 4752 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum